[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 199 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I am Gabi and I'm here with my colleague
John fast hello John hey Gabi how's it
going good how are you I'm pretty good
just came back from my brother's wedding
it was amazing
my sister-in-law she hid the fact that
she was pregnant to all of her guests so
it was pretty awesome and then we ended
up doing the gender reveal at the
wedding and they really wanted a boy and
that's exactly what they're getting
congratulations on that it was great
yeah how about you have you been
puppy City yeah my puppy was really sick
but she's nice she's okay you know yeah
I'm gonna make sure to come visit yeah
so the subject today is super cool we
have a peek on what Google does to make
data visualization consistent across
multiple areas within Google we're gonna
be talking with mano Lima he's the lead
designer at Google cloud for data
visualization team and for a sneak peek
at what our question of the week is what
are the most common products using cloud
gaming and he's gonna reply after
everything yeah yeah I got asked this by
a fellow Googler and I went on a rant
for a while and they were kind of
interested to see how many products are
actually used in cloud gaming so I will
give you a few that I've worked with and
a few that I've seen most commonly used
in a lot of our gaming products now two
are cool things of the week
[Applause]
we have some two new trainings with DC
there are five courses for introduction
to advanced topics and four ones in gke
Google Coronet angel with four courses
on networking persistent storage and
other concepts that you use in
communities reminding you that coronet
is by default stateless so if you want
to do a stateful thing you need to see
the course or read the docs because it's
a bit different my cool thing in the
week is that stadia is coming next month
of course I'm gonna be very excited
about it I've got to use it hands-on
both at i/o and they had an internal
event at the game summit where we got to
play with it for a bit so it's kind of
amazing I can't wait
feel free to check out the show notes
for more information but it should
release on November 19th of this year
and the one thing I'm really excited for
is I'm looking forward to playing in 4k
but I don't need a 4k gaming monitor you
can use a standard monitor because the
resolution is up to 4k at 60 frames per
second so that's what most 4k monitors
that you will see like most recent
monitors will output if it's not in a
specific 4k gaming monitor so I'm really
excited about that and a lot of the
games that got announced that I've been
playing as a kid when they announced
those games like I was jumping out of my
seat so I'm just way too ever excited
for it I will send you the link off my
TV model it's 4k I don't know if it
works you're gonna have to tell me later
the great thing is that most TVs will
probably output at 60 frames but there
are some older models that will do 4k at
30 frames so it's just a small change
when you're avid gamer like myself you
notice the big difference between the
response time and refresh rate of
monitors so okay my second cool thing of
the week RPG was elected by Gartner
Magic Quadrant on the fourth time in a
row as a leader for the full psycho API
management in this year's report so if
you look at the quadrant now you need to
read the full report
you cannot just see the graphic of the
quadrants you should look at everything
but it puts us on highest ability to
execute for api's enterprising most
things have api's including games job
so yeah gave it a look it's on the show
notes the links for always saving here
and I just thought of something new that
just happened today so there was a
Google Hardware event that I'm not sure
if many of our listeners have seen but
we announced a bunch of new products
such as the pixel for new pixel buds as
well as a couple of new nest services so
if you're really interested in those
things you want to you know have connect
at home probably a new phone and also if
they announced a new pixel book which is
kind of amazing which I will be looking
forward to you possibly using in my
classroom feel free to check out the
event and the link to the event will be
posted in the show notes so now we're
gonna be talking with mano Lima about
data visualization and I hope you don't
enjoy
[Music]
we're here today with Manuel Lima so
Manuel who are you and what do you do I
am a designer by training muscle
researcher and writer and I work as a
design leads for Google managing data
visualization team as part of Google
cloud you mentioned that to work for
disappear specifically so why is
visualization important to disappear and
Google in general
well Google in general because if you
look at Google's mission right to
organize the world's information and
make it universally accessible and
useful data visualization plays a huge
role specifically in making information
accessible and useful right we tend to
say that data visualization makes the
invisible visible right in the sense we
are able to decode meaningful patterns
in data right and that's super critical
for googles mission overall it can also
be a huge differentiator for GCP
specifically since we have a lot of
really complex challenges dealing with
data analytics and data analysis across
across GCP do you work together if like
the big query team or stuff like that
yeah we act as an oriental team that's
how we frame it or example team being
that we are not part of one specific
product we work across multiple products
so we tend to partner with multiple
teams within GCP and even across Google
question how was your team actually
formed like if you work with almost
every single team I could imagine that
there has this big business for years to
be formed and to be aligned with so many
different teams there has to be like
importance absolutely many of the
original founders of this team we we
call ourselves the Four Musketeers this
sort of the core four-person team that
created this group in the first place we
were actually working on stackdriver we
were part of the original cloud devops
group so stackdriver was a google
acquisition I would say maybe five or
six years ago and they do a lot of
monitoring rights monitoring different
services servers so you can imagine
there's a lot of data visualization
elements to it right
many complexity from dashboards
using line charts bar charts and so on
to visualize again services
infrastructures and so on so we being
part of that original team we're already
very compelled to be in that space we
are all very passionate about data
visualization but at some moment in time
we felt there was a huge demand for more
complex sophisticated visualizations and
not just by sight drive alone but many
other teams so what I did is that I went
across Google and talked to various
teams that we're doing related work and
there was again a lot of demand for this
type of thinking this really
sophisticated more advanced
visualization models and you can think
about this not as your typical bar chart
or your pie chart but something like a
network visualization right something
like a really sophisticated time line
these are not the things that are
available at the simplest data
visualization tool kits available out
there so the demand was definitely there
however there was not a lot of teams
able to build it as we wanted as we need
it for GCP so I was able to convince our
leadership that this was a you know a
huge sort of opportunity so I was able
to build that team from scratch and I
think now we are around 14 people and a
mix of UX designers researchers UX
engineers essentially prototypers and
software engineers actually building
some of the components that we are
creating awesome so you said something
very interesting you had to convince
leadership that this was very important
so can you tell our listeners why data
visualization is so important I'd like
to think about this one way is called
the understanding spectrum this is how
data converts into information
information converts into knowledge and
knowledge converts into wisdom right
this is the understanding spectrum
normally now data visualization really
comes in in building a bridge between
information and knowledge which is also
the hardest part information surrounds
us every single day right and our
ability to actually generate data and
information as by far outpaced our
ability to actually make sense of that
data and that's what data visualization
can come in it's almost a lens
or understanding right it allows us to
understand in a graphical way a lot of
the Eden patterns in the data and in
information that you wouldn't see
otherwise so that's the metaphor of like
making the invisible visible is so
powerful so if you can tell us what your
team has been up to lately yeah that's a
great question so we've been pretty busy
our team is kind of operating in various
France
we of course act as consultants
internally right we help a lot of teams
again mostly in cloud and GCV but even
in other areas teams that are dealing
with complex issues pertaining to data
visualization right maybe they are
building another chart they are building
this you know sophisticated dashboard
some of these challenges are external
facing that you know our customers
outside let's say Google Analytics for
example but other are internal right we
have a lot of internal dashboards a lot
of internal tools that deal with really
sophisticated ways of visualizing data
and information and we can men as
consultants we support them we help them
achieve a better product overall and
also of course we provide a lot of UX
expertise so we help with usability with
accessibility and things of that nature
we are also very passionate about data
vis and teaching data vis so we organize
you know things like an internal speaker
series where people come in and talk
about the work we teach data
visualization in this internal almost
university that we have at Google we
teach other Googlers on data
visualization but the core of what we do
is really building clot charts which is
a set of data visualization components
so that other teams can actually reuse
them in an easy way
right that's the core of our business
that's the you know where most of us are
really working hard on and a secondary
pillar that we are trying to build is is
related to design ops right design
operations and we are building some
tools and apps a data visualization
related to our part of teams be more
effective collaborate better and just
raise the quality of their output you
said sorry yeah yeah just to go back you
sound like you teach a lot of people
about data visualization right
how much masa do you need like I don't
do math for a long time yeah that's a
you know common misunderstanding I have
to say it like it was kind of like that
maybe I would say 10 to 15 years ago if
you wanted to do any type of substantial
work in data visualization you would
have to you know be good at math and and
also like have a good understanding of a
programming language these days you've
had there was this democratization of
visualization tools so it's pretty easy
for many other people without had the
expertise without that knowledge to you
know do some really substantial work in
this domain right and I think that
that's been really productive because it
has allowed the field to grow immensely
and include many different people from
many different disciplines right awesome
so you've mentioned that you worked on a
bunch of tooling you work with a bunch
of teams and you do a lot of courses so
I'm curious since the team was found by
you know the four of you what has really
come out of the data visualization team
that you can puff your chest out about
that's good I mean stuffing the team was
really fun I'm of course our UX manager
so I love growing teams you know like
finding the right culture growing them
in a balanced way making sure that we
have the rise you know cross discipline
ratios and making sure we are building
the right talent in part of that group
of people so I love that that is one of
the things that I feel most proud of
just building a team from scratch right
with the right capability everyone being
so passionate for this domain just
definitely helps and I feel this is also
something that I carried around with my
career I believe that passion is a
magnet it contaminates others and it
allows you to do a lot more right and I
feel like we have done so much with a
small group of people because we have
that drive because we have that huge
passion for data visualization but one
of the things that I feel again it's
Stefan the team but also reaching out
right a lot of times we do amazing work
internally at Google but we don't
actually go outside and actually talk to
other people and teach them as well what
are we doing so a few months back we
partnered with the material team and we
actually launched externally for
everyone to use so everyone that's
listening to us can actually go and see
a set of data visualization guy
that we did in partnership with material
detailing things like the graphical
language that he should use our type of
charts you need for a given situation a
lot of really interesting principles and
this has been extremely successful I
think right now that material section
has been seen by around 100,000 unique
users and the principles that we
published on medium has been seen by a
roughly like sixty thousand people so
there's definitely a lot of appetite a
lot of interest for this type of
material and I'm really proud for us to
be reaching out to our users outside of
Google awesome so I'm gonna circle back
to a bunch of the tooling that you've
mentioned and a lot of the teams that
you work with for your team you're all
very passionate about data visualization
but curious this everybody need to be an
expert on data or just be passionate
about it to actually get into this
that's a good point I think passion
Alpes but we have had people joining the
team that didn't have a solid sort of
back from their expertise in this space
right they were like just tremendous
researchers or tremendous designers and
they just had that appetite for it right
so I think you can definitely excel but
again in my view passion goes a long way
right it just allows you to that that
extra 10% of dedication so what you
build is basically a set of guidelines
for data visualization the people we use
across different teams how hard was
build something like that because like
the fact that she or is either
horizontal team there is a kind of
uniformity to everything that you're
doing and so it's more common across the
products and how do you work to maintain
that kind of identity I think that's one
of the challenges right and I'm sure you
the audience is probably familiar with
the material team the material team is
this internal group that really strives
to build consistency in terms of the UI
in UX across our various products right
Google products which is a huge
challenge on its own right so we in some
ways are a smaller material team but
just focused on data visualization right
so we have the same challenge all by the
much smaller teams right but you're
right I think it comes in two ways one
is the guidelines
and then the other one is providing the
specific components that others can use
right and they kind of go any in hand on
the guidelines the work that we did kind
of started earlier on I would say maybe
18 months ago or even two years ago the
first time is when a group of us across
Google got together I think we did a
couple of Sprint's on this and this was
a really wild effort this was I think 12
different product areas across Google
from Google Analytics search Google
cloud all these pas that we call
internally so all these designers from
all these groups getting together and
thinking about what would the right set
of guidelines that we could provide in a
unified way so that everyone else on the
team could build the right type of chart
right at the time we were not even
thinking about providing a specific
component that he could actually use
right we was just a set of guidelines
and that became our internal Google bit
of his spec this is again available only
internally and the one that we ended up
publishing by madama the material team
externally is just a subset of that so
internally it's a bit heavier we cover
almost everything from motion design to
interaction we cover aspects of this on
the external one as well but the
internal is far far more comprehensive
that was a really fun project that was
really fun sort of initiative to be part
of that and that has been immensely
helpful for again many different
designers engineers and researchers
across the entire company so that was on
the guidelines aspect of it and then
part of that that we are doing right now
is releasing specific components right
we are building a library a toolkit so
that all the engineers across multiple
different private areas as well and of
course most importantly cloud and GCP
can leverage those components right and
consistency to your point Gabriel is
critical because that's one of the
reasons why we are doing this why we are
building this library in the first place
is that users don't get to see a
different bar chart a different part
chart in every single product that they
navigate through within GCP right that
wouldn't make sense consistency builds
familiarity and it's really important
that people and users recognize the same
type of experience the same type of
charting mechanism across
from products that they use and navigate
to achieve a given task so you brought
up this component library and I'm
curious of course it's used widely
across Google internally but what would
you say is like the biggest advantage of
actually building this out internally of
course things that happen internally
have extreme external benefits for our
users so I'm just curious and what would
you say is like the biggest advantage
for us internally one is definitely
building some of the internal expertise
on this domain which is again still
fairly new to people they understand
maybe the benefit but they don't
understand how critical it can be
forgiving product even an internal
product right so I think it's kind of
raising the awareness and education
across the company is a really good
effort the benefits of building a
library per se is multifold right you
can increase velocity because you don't
have to reinvent the wheel every time
you know you can just pick up the
component and kind of plug and play you
can also minimize a lot of the UI sort
of complexity because you end up
creating like auxilliary type of UI
components that are not productive at
times I think it can really increase
quality optimize UI quality consistency
and effectiveness right we've talked
about consistency it helps build
familiarity the apps that you find the
same type of chart every time you
navigate to a different product and I
think it can be a huge driver for
innovation impressing our customers and
be you know really a differentiator for
GCP as well you said that you have a set
of guidelines and that you built
internally so we kind of like the
formula one like cutting-edge internally
then you put it outside that it's okay
and safe and that kind of stuff so how
is the process to publishing those
guidelines for the outside world it was
easier in the sense that we had a body
of content already to rely on right we
didn't invent this everything from
scratch even though we ended up creating
a bunch of new content just for that
external publishing alone but the
process was really a strong partnership
with the material team we have been very
close since the beginning since our the
inception of our group working very
closely with them reviewing content
several times and they are very of
course familiar with the process and
again we actually published under damage
aiyoh website so they are very familiar
with the whole process of like be
trading on content publishing and and so
on so that was usually alpha right and
then also we published under the Google
design on medium and that's also
co-owned by the material team so that
partnership was was fundamental I would
say and in case you might be wondering
about what this guidelines can be right
so we kind of started off with
principles principles are things that
can be fundamental for users to
understand how do they actually get
started with the APIs our session right
principles might be used for you to
either evaluate a specific data
visualization work a chart that you
working on or even before you even start
doing anything just to start sort of
inspiring and sort of scatter folding
the whole project right so one of the
principles we have for example is be
honest all right
data accuracy and integrity come first
don't distort or confuse information for
embellishment or partiality as with any
form of communication charts data
visualization can be used for good at
that time so being honest being accurate
is really critical for us what we do as
Google right another principal just
index as an example is lend a helping
hand a lot of the charts that we do a
lot of the components we do can be
fairly complex to understand you know
they requires a substantial learning
curve so finding ways of lining a
helping hand right providing the context
and help users navigating the data is
really important building the right
visual for dances right that can comfort
users that this is something that's
doable that they can learn in a fast way
these principles they sound very very
similar to a lot of our core values at
Google so I'm just curious how did these
come about so the principles were a
really interesting project a lot of that
work was from that original team of
designers across Google right those 12
different Pro the areas that we got
together in a few Sprint's that was the
genesis of it we denny traded a few
times we also talked to a lot of
different areas even you know the
hardware team at Google right they have
their own set of principles we have our
own brand principles there's multiple
instances within Google that have their
own sort of specific principles but
there are a few ones that are really
common and shared across
company right so we talked to a bunch of
those people we also use research
research has been really critical for us
very recently we just published
internally a report on data
visualization needs of 3d three
different product things within GCP by
far the most comprehensive research
study we ever conducted and through a
lot of that research we kind of had a
really solid understanding of what users
actually wanted what our customers need
it pertaining to data visualization what
was really important to them and all
these things put together we just mix it
up and we generate a final list of six
guiding principles that we can find on
our medium post and I believe we can
actually surface a link to that article
on the podcast on the show yeah on the
show notes yeah so you've written this
article and it's been amplified outside
apparently this is something new to me
Fast Company actually wrote an article
about the work right so I'm curious how
has this been received yeah I mean my
understanding it has been pre
well-received again like we have had
close to a hundred thousand unique views
on the material section that you can
find on material dot IO other
communication and then a whole section
on the de visualization and then I've
been following on social media it's it's
been you know especially after Fast
Company and if you are the media outlets
talked about it I think it's been pretty
well-received right people are really
interested in what Google has to say
pertaining to data visualization right
and there was also the medium post which
got a lot of buzz on the principles and
I think that people tend to gravitate
for the principles because they are not
eyelas specific they are just more
generative and then prescriptive and I
think that resonates with people a lot
more and we are thinking about doing
enhancements also by the way to those
guidelines on a material I outside right
now there's a lot of content on the
types of charts that you might pick
right sometimes you have a given data
set but you don't really know what chart
you should be using right so we provide
a lot of guidance on that we also
provide guidance on the graphical
language that you need to build right so
I'll to use caller ought to use
typography how to use shape to convey a
given sort of concept so we provide a
lot of guidance and I think people have
found that to be extremely useful right
that's that level of specific
city that we also provide not just the
principles the eye level principles but
also like the do's and don'ts what to do
and what not to do on specific areas of
building a chart and building a data
visualization based on this guideline
Zippo said this principles that you
mentioned is there any outside company
or anyone else outside Google that you
seek successfully implementing this or
in a way that you didn't thought even
that was possible to people to do it
unfortunately I haven't I haven't
actually been contacted or seen anything
of that nature it's more like the kind
of people reaching out to me and saying
hey this was very useful you know we are
using it in a given way but I don't
think I've actually seen tangible output
influenced by our guidelines but maybe
it's just a matter of time we would like
to think manual EEMA for joining us it's
been a pleasure with him right now
currently recorded and you can see how
very passionate he is about data
visualization so it's great to see how
you've really tried to impact internally
with Google and also sharing those those
guidelines and principles with our
external audiences so that's that's
perfect so we will be sure to share all
of these blog posts as well as the
principles in the show notes so that all
of our listeners will be able to follow
along and hopefully we'll see some
adaption of the principles and
guidelines along with you know a general
interest in general data as a relation
and how we go about it that was a really
nice conversation yeah thank you so much
regardez
so back to the question of the week Don
what are the most common products used
in cloud gaming I'll probably go over a
couple but one product that I've seen a
big shift to was cloud spanner customers
have been using cloud spanner to store
like player on occasion data and
inventories or pretty much any long-term
state storage so the great thing about
it it's relatively quick scalable and
highly available so there's been
definitely been a big shift to cloud
spanner another product that's been used
quite often is Redis one of the open
source projects that we work on open
mention comes default with Redis and
it's used for the storage or caching
player data which allows the framework
to actually access that data relatively
quickly in creates very competitive
matches very quickly so that's also
another product than seeing a big shift
towards and it's widely known that VMs
have been used as a product for game
servers but there's been a big shift
kubernetes big shout out to mark and the
aganist project I plug them every week I
can but there's been a big shift to
using cribben IDs because it's highly
scalable and highly available and the
great thing about it is that it auto
scales and I think that whenever one of
your pods goes down and it always spins
right back up the product in itself just
speaks to the power that it would have
in gaming and the last product that I've
been using personally quite a bit for my
personal project is pops up I've been
using it a lot for messaging as well as
sending data relatively quickly between
two clients so pops up is great because
if done right you should have real-time
messaging between two clients so if
you're interested feel free to check out
all of the links for all of these
products in our show notes ok just
reminding people that we do have a
called memory store which is Rattus
compatible so you can be using that too
and the great thing about open match is
that Redis just comes default but pretty
much any component can be swapped out so
if you want to use memory store if you
want to use fire store pretty much
anything that you want to use for you
know storing or caching your player data
you can easily just swap out and that
also goes for pretty much any other
component of the project as well so feel
free to you know check out the notes and
if I can grab a couple of presentations
on it I'll add it along as well
are you gonna be doing what are you
gonna be up to I'm gonna be doing
actually not a database talk but a
server let's talk at full-stack Europe
and then to our Belgian next week I
think I'm gonna be speaking on the 24
for 25 the link of in the show notes and
I'm excited all that because I know a
bit of cauldron I know that app engine
and functions but like it's fun to be
showing the but what those products can
do even if database is connected to them
it's pretty good that you're pretty
versatile we tried to be right right
yeah and for me I will be at cue calm
and November and then I'm gonna doing
quite a bit of personal travel I'll be
in Kirkland to meet with some
engineering teams and then I'll be
hanging out in New York possibly going
to some distant location just for
vacation I'm gonna probably roll a large
sided dice to determine where I'm gonna
land looking forward to just taking the
spontaneous vacation you should go to
Brazil mm-hmm no I can't go to prison
without you remember you're gonna host
oh yeah but I'm going there in the and
December so I can't go
hopefully our timelines a lot okay okay
everybody thank you so much for
listening to the podcast today and have
a good week thanks for listening
[Music]
you